(gentle music)
Dr. Gilmer is returning,
and we're going to talk about the major arthritides.
Dr. Gilmer, I'm gonna ask you to take it away, sir.
Thank you, sir, on that inspiring note.
We are all gonna become rheumatologist here
in the next 30 minutes.
We could spend a whole weekend talking about rheumatology.
These are the things that are the most common questions
on the boards, and they're the most common things
that we see in practice too.
So we'll hit the highlights
of the major arthritic processes, RA, OA,
the spondyloarthropathies, gout,
and then we'll talk about treatment.
34-year-old female with a history of lupus
comes in with acute pain, rubor, calor,
and swelling in her left knee.
She denies any recent trauma and is currently taking
hydroxychloroquine and prednisone.
Her other SLE symptoms have been well-controlled overall.
The most likely cause of this patient's knee pain is,
A, is it an infectious process?
Is it a patellofemoral syndrome?
Is it RA?
Or is this an SLE flare?
All right, let's see what we got.
So this is a learning opportunity here.
Most of you got this right, infectious arthritis.
This is the most important diagnosis to make.
And Dr. Gary was referring to this
when he was talking about the synovitis
versus an infectious process.
But identifying a monoarticular joint
that could be infected is the first question
that you should ask.
Is it an infection or not?
In general, when you're looking at
all of the articular diseases, and there are so many,
try to put them in one of three buckets.
So is it a monoarticular process, as in this patient?
Is it a symmetric polyarticular process?
Or is it an asymmetric polyarticular process?
So this was the acute monoarthritis, that was an infection.
So the most critical diagnosis to make.
It's an inflammation, the rubor, calor in one single joint.
Most commonly, it's gonna be strep
followed by MRSA, and then GAS and GBS in adults.
So this is a list of all the different possibilities
to think about when you're imagining the differential
with a common monoarticular process.
So these are usually the non-rheumatologic ones,
although sometimes you can have a, you know, RA can,
or JRA can start with a single joint.
Most of the time they don't.
So the common monoarticular ones are these like crystals.
Is that OA in a single joint?
Trauma was their previous infection.
Don't forget to consider neoplasm.
Is this an overuse injury?
Or is this some type of vascular process
in that single joint?
And we'll come back and talk about
all the other ones here briefly.
These are the symmetric polyarthritides.
Most of them you notice are
have some rheumatologic component, but not all of them.
We'll come back to RA.
We're not gonna talk much about SLE today.
So I would encourage you to go back at some point,
and just take a peek at SLE.
Remembering that they have commonly found skin findings.
PMR, we're not gonna talk about today either.
But PMR is something to go back and take a quick review.
Most commonly affecting the proximal muscles
in the shoulders and in your hip flexors.
Lyme's disease, there's a slide in your supplementary slides
about Lymes.
We're not gonna spend much time there.
We'll come back to CPPD, pseudogout, sarcoid.
Don't forget those hilar, the hilar lymphadenopathy.
And then we'll come back to the
spondyloarthropathies briefly.
So just a moment to think about
the mechanics of during your exam,
if you wanna grab your right arm, you know,
when you're thinking about active range of motion, you know,
if you wanna stretch it out, active range of motion,
you're talking about pain associated
with a periarticular process.
In contrast with a passive pain
with passive range of motion,
that's gonna be an intra-articular process.
So is it passive or active?
Is it a single joint or multiple joints?
Is this a mechanical versus an inflammatory process?
These three questions will help get you started
towards building your differential.
This is a good kinda review slide to put a star on
thinking about some hallmark signs
that make great board questions.
Again, active range of motion.
Thinking about the periarticular process.
If you have eye involvement,
think about an ankylosing spondylitis,
that's your number one spondyloarthropathy.
If you have a coagulopathy,
think about a hemarthrosis.
We'll come back to stones, diuretics, et cetera.
That's gonna be more likely a gout process.
There again is your hilar adenopathy
associated with sarcoid.
As in this first patient, this immunosuppressed patient,
you always have to think about infection
in septic arthritis.
The insidious onset of pain,
most commonly osteoarthritis.
Was there a previous attack with resolution?
Think crystals, think CPPD or gout.
Skin lesions, think psoriatic arthritis.
We'll come back to some of these again.
But here's another question.
It's a 59-year-old female presents with symptoms of fatigue,
mild weight loss, morning stiffness in both hands
lasting more than an hour.
She notes worsening tenderness in her MCPs
and her DIP's bilaterally.
Which of the following is the most specific
to the diagnosis of this inflammatory process?
Is it a high ESR?
A positive ANA?
Rheumatoid joint erosions?
Or a rheumatoid factor?
Which is the most specific in making this diagnosis?
Good.
So this is kind of a test-taking question to think about.
All of these other surrogate markers
are fairly nonspecific overall.
Joint erosion seen on x-ray
will definitely be the most specific.
So this is kind of a test-taking approach
to this question.
The other marker that we could have added here
is the anti-citrullinated protein antibody,
which happens to be the most specific
of the biologic markers, the ECPA.
That's your most specific.
High ESR, positive ANA can be positive.
Rheumatoid factor is positive in like 80%.
But these joint erosion seen on radiograph
are the most specific for sure.
So when using the joint score classification,
which of the following does not contribute
towards a diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis?
So A, 4 to 10 small joints affected.
A positive sed rate.
Duration of symptoms less than six weeks.
Or there is your positive ACPA?
Good, awesome.
So all of these contribute
except symptoms less than six weeks.
So generally you would have symptoms greater than six weeks.
But all of these others, positive ACPA,
4 to 10 small joints.
As you would see in the criteria for rheumatoid arthritis,
which are broken down into four primary buckets.
Number of small joints.
Your serology, as we just mentioned.
Your acute phase reactants, and the duration of symptoms.
So you're gonna get more points greater than six
as it rules you in unequivocally more points
for increased number of small joints versus large joints.
So this is a great way to,
pretty easy way to diagnose rheumatoid arthritis,
which generally isn't the diagnosis
is not typically the problem, right?
The problem since few of us have like immediate access
to rheumatology is starting the therapy.
Don't forget that their rheumatoid arthritis
is both an intraarticular process,
but it's also an extra articular process.
So there are lots of things that happen outside
of the joints with rheumatoid disease.
In fact, most people who die of rheumatoid disease,
they don't die because of their rheumatoid disease,
they die from a heart attack.
Because it's a chronic inflammatory process
that contributes to CAD.
But it also contributes to all these other things,
because it can affect every organ system.
So just to make a note of that.
So you do make the diagnosis.
You're pretty sure you've ruled them in
with greater than six points,
and you decide they have the disease.
It's a Friday afternoon, what do you do?
When should you start using the disease,
modulating anti-rheumatic medications?
Immediately?
Following three months of NSAID conservative therapy?
Following a five-day burst of steroids?
Or only after the patient has failed conservative therapy?
So when do you start a DMARD on a Friday afternoon?
Good.
So this is all in our wheelhouse, right?
To start a DMARD.
And we'll talk about the different types of DMARDs.
But as soon as you make the diagnosis of RA,
RA is a ticking time bomb.
So joints matter, and the sooner you intervene,
this is a concept that I don't,
it took me a while to realize,
but the sooner you intervene in an acute RA flare,
whether it be the first one or the second one,
or the third one, the greater the likelihood
of having actual remission.
So this is, you know, as neurons are to a stroke,
you know, joints are to RA.
And so the timeliness of initiating therapy
is very, very important.
So typically if it is a Friday afternoon,
typically we would load them on steroids,
but we would also start them on methotrexate.
I don't know about you all,
but in our community in Asheville,
I mean there's like a six month wait
to get into to rheumatology these days.
It's almost impossible.
And so most of us have become very familiar
with how to treat RA without a rheumatologist.
Don't hesitate to pull the trigger on methotrexate
on that Friday afternoon.
You typically start with 7.5 milligrams,
but you wanna try to get up to 15 milligrams per week,
not per day, but per week, within at least six weeks.
So that's the goal.
It's a fairly rapid titration of methotrexate
along with your folic acid, which is very important.
You don't wanna exceed 20 milligrams per week.
And then you have your other arsenal of non-biologics.
These are all on the table for you too.
And say for example, you live in an area where you truly
don't have any access to rheumatology,
and you truly have difficulty like finding a biologic DMARD,
then it's okay to use triple therapy.
So triple therapy is very, very effective
with non-biologic agents.
So that would include primarily methotrexate, leflunomide,
hydroxychloroquine, and sulfasalazine.
So one of those, you can use three of those four initially.
What you would just use methotrexate initially.
If you don't get control,
then you can use the triple therapy non-biologics,
if you don't have access to a biologic.
So that just something to consider.
These are your biologics.
So most of them are TNF-alpha inhibitors.
Orencia is, the last one, there is not a TNF-alpha biologic,
it's a T-cell inhibitor.
There are some newer classes of biologics that are emerging.
There's some anti-CD20.
Once the anti-T-cell inhibitors, those are emerging,
but these are the work horses of the biologic agents.
None of them is superior to another.
So it doesn't really matter which one you start.
Most importantly, it's which one their insurance company
will afford.
If you're gonna start a biologic agent,
and it's okay to start.
So the patient comes in, you've given them steroids.
At six weeks, they're still flared,
and you're a little trepidatious about starting
triple therapy and you want to add a biologic agent.
It's okay to use a non-biologic agent
and a biologic agent together.
That is okay.
You don't, however, wanna use two biologic agents
at the same time.
So you would never use Enbrel or Remicade at the same time.
No insurance company would pay for it anyway.
But you wanna avoid using two biologics together.
If you're gonna start a biologic agent,
you need to really do four things.
You need to check a PPD,
'cause the TB could be reactivated.
You wanna check it hep B.
You also wanna consider checking a hep C.
And if your patient has a history of melanoma,
you should do send them to derm,
or do an exhaustive exam,
because there is a slight increased risk
of melanoma reactivation in a patient
who's had previous history of skin cancer.
Here are your practice recommendations
that kind of sum those things up.
Again, no regimen of monotherapy is superior to any other.
Don't forget your cardiovascular disease.
This associated with RA.
So this is a category that the major spondyloarthropathies
that they're sort of, I don't know, it might,
they're difficult to put into a box,
because they're very different.
But they are put into this bucket,
because they can all potentially affect the spine
to some degree.
But they're very unique.
These are the primary ones,
and we'll go through each of them.
So ankylosing spondylitis.
If there's gonna be a spondyloarthropathy question
on the boards, it's gonna be this one.
It's the number one.
The prevalence is low,
but it's still number one at 0.1 to .2%.
This is the disease.
You probably remember the HLA-B27 that can be associated
with this spondyloarthropathy.
In fact, 95% of people who have ankylosing spondylitis
are positive for HLA-B27, 95%.
However, of all of you who have,
who are positive for HLA-B27, you just have a 1% risk
of developing ankylosing spondylitis.
Caucasians have a greater prevalence.
There's a 10% of Caucasians are positive for HLA-B27,
and 2% of African Americans are positive for HLA-B27.
The symptomology is very consistent with this description
that the pain starts in your lower back.
It's insidious, it can radiate to the glute.
Oftentimes worse in the morning, improves with activity,
but they can also have nocturnal symptoms.
Enthesitis is very common.
So enthesitis is where the tendon joins,
connects with the bone.
And so it's that interface that can be inflamed
most commonly with ankylosing spondylitis.
You can also see eye issues.
So that's a common board question, sort of star is the eye,
the anterior uveitis.
And people respond very quickly initially with NSAIDs,
so that could be sort of a diagnostic
that could help you with a diagnosis.
So if you put them on high dose NSAIDs
on the Friday afternoon, and they get better on Monday,
that's a good indicator that this could be
ankylosing spondylitis.
If they have progressive joint disease,
you don't obviously wanna keep them on NSAIDs forever,
you're gonna use a biologic agent.
So that is ankylosing spondylitis.
This person is a 35-year-old with a three-month history
of an asymmetric polyarthritis
that's noted in six separate joints.
And on exam, you see the pitting of the fingernails
along with a scaly silver rash on both elbows.
Which treatment has been shown to delay further progression
of these joint erosions.
Etanercept, that's Enbrel.
Methotrexate, naproxen, or sulfasalazine.
Good.
Basically you have a decision-making point
between a biologic, a non-biologic, an NSAID,
and essentially another NSAID.
So you can get rid of C and D, get rid of those.
So then what is always gonna be more potent,
a biologic agent versus a non-biologic agent?
Usually the biologic agents will,
will generally always be more potent.
So it is the best for decreasing joint erosions.
These are hallmark features of psoriatic arthritis.
You see the pitting in the nails.
You see the oligoarthritis.
Oligoarthritis means the distal extremities
commonly in the hands,
the dactylitis that you see with this patient.
Most of the time, it's an asymmetric oligoarticular process.
But the nail changes are very common.
This can look like rheumatoid arthritis,
but there are no rheumatoid nodules
that you would see with RA.
And that the disease can be rapidly destructive.
So this is a disease process that also demands
like very acute intervention.
And because it's a spondyloarthropathy,
you're gonna have axial involvement as well.
HIV can make it worse.
So not every psoriatic arthritic patient
will have the presence of psoriasis by itself,
but up to 20% of people who have psoriasis
can develop the arthritic process.
So typically the psoriasis precedes the arthritic process,
and up to 75% of times,
nail changes is noted are very prevalent.
Dactylitis, uveitis are very prevalent.
There's no difference in like the run of the mill psoriasis
and the psoriasis that you would see
with a psoriatic arthritis.
It's exactly the same.
The same places that you would see psoriasis,
you see them with psoriatic arthritis.
So the scalp, extensor surfaces, anal cleft, umbilicus,
et cetera.
This is a good review slide.
Go ahead and put a star on that to come back
that this is how you risk stratify
with a point system psoriatic arthritis.
And again, start your treatment early,
DMARDs are the most effective,
the biologic ones in particular.
If you don't have access to the biologics,
then the non-biologics can be helpful.
And NSAIDs can also be helpful in the short term.
How about reactive arthritides?
The reactive arthritides I feel like we,
I don't know about you all,
but I feel like we saw a lot more of them during COVID.
They seem to be more common.
The Reiter's triad is that classic one.
Can't pee, can't see, can't climb a tree.
So the urethritis, the conjunctivitis,
and then the arthritis.
Usually the symptoms begin just one to four weeks
after whatever infection preceded those infections
are commonly ones that can be associated
with bloody diarrhea.
So that will be Salmonella, Shigella, Yersinia, et cetera.
Chlamydia is also a big player.
Usually it's asymmetric,
and usually it affects multiple joints.
Here are the recommendations that you can go back
to take a look at them as a review.
So typically, these are interestingly,
they're typically provoked by a bacterial etiology.
However, antibiotics have never been shown
to be effective for reactive arthritis.
Almost everything else has been shown to be effective
with a reactive arthritis.
So that includes a biologic agents, that includes steroids,
that includes NSAIDs.
Here's an older gentleman, previous painter.
He comes in with chronic right dull hand pain.
States his DIPs and PIPs are the most tender.
So those your distal interphalangeal joints
in your proximal interphalangeal joints.
But not his MCP.
So here's your MCP.
On exam, there's mild swelling in the DIP/PIP distribution,
but no rubor, no calor.
It's not hot, it's not inflamed.
Which of the following is not consistent
with this diagnosis?
Osteophytes?
Changes in the joint alignment?
Heberden's nodes?
Or MCP inflammation?
So this is a question asking you to differentiate
between OA and RA.
And it's okay, you can use your hand.
Good, good.
So this is a very commonly board-type question.
So the MCP inflammation here is associated with RA,
not with osteoarthritis.
So DIPs, PIPs, those are associated with osteo.
Osteo is the pathophy is very simple.
It's like the number of Newtons per surface area.
It's a wear and tear process.
So it's not a systemic process.
It's not an inflammatory process.
It's simply a wear and tear process.
So you don't see the systemic findings.
You don't see the rubor, calor.
You don't see the inflamed joints.
And you especially don't see them in the MCP.
Transient stiffness is a hallmark.
It's insidious in its onset overall.
And you see them in your hands,
in your weight-bearing joints, most commonly,
because of the force.
Here's a classic picture of the joint space narrowing
in the hips.
Notice there's not much space there anymore.
Here is the, notice the medial compartment of the knee,
common especially in women
that is classic for osteoarthritis.
You could see the osteophytes
that are starting to burge in there.
So here's the problem, like how do we manage osteoarthritis?
We've heard lots of things,
but you know, the best mechanism is gonna be an NSAID.
But you don't wanna do NSAIDs forever.
So using transdermal NSAIDs
really is the first line of defense.
Acetaminophen is equal to placebo.
There's no benefit to using acetaminophen with an NSAID
for chronic osteoarthritis.
We hear lots of things, right?
But there's no benefit to using acetaminophen
for chronic osteoarthritis.
Walking aids, weight loss, physiotherapy,
all these things can be very helpful.
And we'll come back to injections too.
So topical NSAIDs are most likely
the most effective in the long term,
because we don't wanna use NSAIDs for the long term orally.
Acupuncture, some benefit there.
And then the question always is,
what about steroid injections?
What about Synvisc?
What about hyaluronic acid injections?
The data is just not good.
The data is not great.
There's some beneficial data in the very, very short term
for steroid injections in large weight-bearing joints.
But there's very little data for hyaluronic acid.
In fact, the AAFP does not endorse using hyaluronic acid
for large joint osteoarthritis.
We see it all the time though.
There is some data to show that ultrasound injections,
if you are gonna do an injection in the shoulder,
if you're gonna do one in the hip, even in the knee,
the ultrasound-guided injections can have greater benefit
than non-ultrasound guided injections.
So there's pretty decent data to show
just a little bit of differentiation.
What's not recommended are these.
So put a big star on these.
TENS units.
Glucosamine, chondroitin, we see that all the time.
No data for it.
Acetaminophen, no data for it.
No data for NSAIDs, plus acetaminophen.
And then very little data for the biologic injections
and for even steroid injections,
certainly not in the long term.
If you're gonna use the NSAID, use a transdermal one first.
So this is coming back to renal stones.
Love it.
53-year-old male with history of renal stones
comes in with a really painful great toe.
I think you know what that is.
Started last night.
He didn't have a fever, no rashes,
no other systemic symptoms.
Which diagnostic feature is most specific
to this inflammatory process?
Is it elevated uric acid greater than 6.8?
Negatively birefringent crystals?
Radiographic evidence of joint erosions?
Or positively birefringent crystals?
This question just keeps coming back, doesn't it?
When is it gonna end, the crystal question?
We got this.
Oh, we didn't get it.
(audience laughing)
So what is this?
Gout?
It's gout.
So gout forever for the rest of your lives
will always be negatively birefringent crystals.
Pseudogout, which starts with a P, starts with a P.
Pseudogout, P, is the positively birefringent crystals.
So don't even waste a single additional neuron
thinking about that question again,
which you will see again.
But gout is negatively birefringent crystals.
Gout, the disease of kings.
I think that the symptoms you, everybody's well aware of,
the vast majority of initial symptoms are the podagra.
This is greater than 50% of the time.
You don't see the systemic symptoms.
And be very careful,
because 20% of gout patients also have renal stones.
And during the Q and A,
we'll talk a little bit more about renal stones.
But always remember thiazides are great
if you have renal stones,
but they're terrible if you have gout.
Everybody got that?
Yeah.
These are the four stages of gout.
You can go back and take a look.
You know, it takes a while for the uric acid to build up
before you eventually start having degradation
in the joint itself.
And hyperuricemia alone is not sufficient
to make a diagnosis of gout.
You need to see the crystals,
unless they have a history, they've had crystals before.
6.8 is the magic number.
It's at that point the crystals start to diffuse out
into the joint space.
So your goal, uric acid is less than six.
That's your goal.
There we go, negatively birefringent crystals.
A little bit about pseudogout.
Sometimes it's very hard to distinguish
between pseudogout and gout.
Oftentimes precipitated by illness, stress, surgery,
more commonly associated with the knee rather than the toe.
So that's a good one to remember.
But it could also be in any joint.
So that could be confusing too.
So what causes gout?
You hear lots of things.
Don't drink, don't eat a lot of meat.
Those things can be true.
Here, you're relative risk for,
if you have a high protein diet,
but it's actually high fructose corn syrup
that puts you at the greatest risk of having gout.
So obesity, high fructose corn syrup diet,
overall, too much energy substrate
that you're consuming can put you at a greater risk of gout.
How many of you have a patient
on one of these antihypertensives?
(Benjamin laughs)
All of them, right?
So this is a great slide to remember,
because losartan and calcium channel blockers
are the two anti-hypertensives
that you wanna turn to every time.
Losartan and amlodipine.
Those are the two anti-hypertensives that are preferential.
All of the others, especially the thiazides,
you want to avoid if you have a patient with suspected gout.
There's pretty big numbers relative risk of 2.4.
So this is a slide that oftentimes
people have a little bit of confusion.
And I think this is a great learning opportunity
in this moment, because we make this mistake,
our residents make this mistake all the time.
Someone has an acute gout flare,
and you start treatment on a Friday afternoon.
Normally you're gonna start with whatever you have,
colchicine, NSAIDs, steroids.
All of those things are equally efficacious.
However, you don't wanna treat someone with steroids
for six months.
You don't wanna treat someone with NSAIDs for six months.
So colchicine actually is the best initiating medicine
for acute prophylaxis.
A lot of people will stop the acute prophylaxis,
whatever NSAID, anti-inflammatory you use,
after they come back maybe in a month.
But the data is this.
The data is to treat with acute anti-inflammatories
for the better of six months.
If you're gonna remember one thing,
just treat for six months with anti-inflammatories
after that flare, or be evidence to treat for three months
after you've achieved a target goal of uric acid.
We're certainly six months after achieving
target goal of uric acid if you have tophi.
So tophi will indicate, you know, more severe disease.
So continue your colchicine for six months.
Another learning point.
There's no great benefit of high dose colchicine
compared to low dose colchicine.
They're the same.
You just get more GI side effects,
the more you increase the dose.
So it's okay to start with, you know,
two tablets of colchicine per day.
And then after they've been stable for a while,
you just decrease them to one tablet of colchicine per day
with or without your uric acid lowering agent.
So this is when you should use a uric acid lowering agent.
And the number one uric acid lowering agent
is still allopurinol.
You don't need to use Uloric febuxostat.
So if you have tophi, if you have frequent attacks
greater than two per year, if you have kidney disease,
if you have gout with kidney stones,
then you need to use a uric acid lowering agent.
Here are the American College
of Rheumatology recommendations,
which kinda sum up what we just talked about.
And that is it for that.
I just wanna make one note.
When you are using allopurinol,
the great risk of allopurinol
as a type one hypersensitivity reaction,
and that can happen in 1% of cases.
And of those 1%, some of them die.
So allopurinol can be a dangerous drug.
There's a new genetic marker.
So there's a much greater risk in folks who come from Asia.
And there's a genetic test that you can do
for a very specific HLA-5801 marker.
And that can help tell you if you have that gene.
If you don't have the gene, use allopurinol.
If you do have that gene,
that's when you would use the Uloric.
Otherwise, just use allopurinol.
Start with 100 milligrams and then titrate slowly.
I think it's time now for some questions.
In the back, there are some supplemental slides
that have a little bit more about
some of the other nuanced tests
that you might use for SLE, et cetera,
that can guide you in that way.
(gentle music)